Welcome back everyone this is my full Shang
Chi movie review they're finally releasing
it around the world hopefully had a chance
to see it.
If not I recommend you go check it out.
I will also be doing full Easter egg breakdowns
post credit scene videos the next couple of
days to.
So if you're new to my channel, be sure to
subscribe to get all those for those of you
who are huge martial arts movie fans and you're
really really bummed out by what they did
with iron fist, the Shang Chi movie is a giant
step in the correct direction and it basically
the beginning of this giant new franchise
in a direction that Marvel has ever gone before
I made the Black Panther movie comparison
before where is that movie sort of set this
whole new area inside the MCU.
This whole new mythology that wasn't anything
like any of the other marvel movies that come
before.
So even though he's going to eventually crossover
with the avengers is a sort of tease through
the course the film all explained that in
the second to do a really good job of asking
a bunch of questions during the film that
you are excited to watch them answer in future
sequels.
They answer most of the big questions that
they raised during the film like the biggest
things about his character.
Where does he come from how to his powers
work what's going on with the Mandarin how
do these characters connect with the rest
of the Marvel films, but also at the same
time raise a couple other big questions that
they will answer till they get to the second
film.
Kevin Feige is Artie said they have a lot
of ideas what is going to pick up, but they
haven't given any kind of release date to
that yet.
And where is the black widow movie dealt with
a little bit of marvel phase 4 stuff like
the black widow post credit scene was a marvel
phase 4 scene because there's a huge time
jump at the end the movie till after avengers
endgame.
And even though Spider-Man Far From Home actually
takes place after Shang Chi in the timeline
of marvel movies so it should be a marvel
phase 4 film that was really more of an epilogue
the way they built it for Avengers endgame
in all the marvel phase 3 stuff.
So, Shang Chi takes place before the events
of Spider-Man Far From Home.
But it actually feels like a genuine marvel
phase 4 movie where everything is new and
it's pushing the plot forward in marvel phase
4.
The way you would expect a marvel movie to
do it if there was confusion about when this
does take place in the timeline.
It does take place after the events of Avengers
endgame.
Like a good while after endgame after things
of chilled out like his gotten back to normal
around the time I would say falcon and winter
soldier's happening.
But before the events of Spider-Man Far From
Home, and Spider-Man No Way Home.
Because you do see the sanctum during the
movie and it's not covered in snow and Wong
isn't talking about it or addressing any kind
of issues there happening at the sanctum so
clearly whatever's happening at the sanctum
during the Spider-Man No Way Home trailer
is happening after the events of the Shang
Chi movie Kevin Feige a lot of you the producers
were also talking about a lot of cameos in
the crossovers like you have abomination and
Wong showing up during the movie very clearly
during the trailers this they also considered
having the ant-man character show up during
the film I feel like it's not a huge spoiler
to say that there are no big Ant-Man characters
that show up during the film.
Even though good chunk of the film at the
Beginning Takes place in San Francisco.
There were a lot of questions about that early
on.
Like this on the bus chase happening through
San Francisco, so people wonder wait a minute.
This is the exact same area were Antman and
the wasp took place.
But the way they said they want to keep the
movie relatively self-contained which gets
back to the whole Black Panther of it all
Black Panther did crossover with other marvel
movies were some continuity tying it to Captain
America Civil War in avengers infinity war.
Because that was the next movie happening
right after so you have that white will post
credit scene where shuri shows up, but they
didn't mention avengers infinity war during
that is very self-contained the Shang Chi
movie felt like they built it to be that way
to you could watch this movie without having
seen some of the other marvel movies.
But there are a lot of Easter eggs in background
details tying it to of the previous marvel
movies.
They even use some footage from other marvel
movies inside this movie most of that was
in service of paying off the iron man Easter
eggs in the Iron Man films the way they talked
about the Mandarin during those, if you have
been following the Marvel movies since early
2006 when they announced the Iron Man film
they were going to make one and they were
building up to the avengers.
Kevin Feige was teasing the avengers even
back in 2006 long before they did the first
Iron Man film studios work hours or more of
an opportunity for crossover here and there
Marvel characters associated might show up
in a hulk movie down the road if you you listen
to the characters.
I name it we that we work working on currently
and put them all together, there's no coincidence
that that may someday for the avengers.
I think you may remember that 2006 comic con.
He said they were going to use the Mandarin
as the villain of the film, but then when
they got into production famously pivoted
and changed it to obidiah stane since then
they've already kind of answered a lot of
those questions.
But this film actually does fill in a lot
of the gaps some really important parts of
the Shang Chi movie are dedicated to filling
in those gaps in fixing some of those past
mistakes that they made so I was happy to
see that they're trying to explain know know
know it was Wenwu Tony Leung's version of
the Mandarin this whole time influencing things
he was behind the events of Iron Man one is
just you didn't see him till now seemingly
was great is the Shang Chi character.
He's one of those actors who can do a lot
of the action stuff himself because is that
she really good martial arts just on his own,
but he can also do all the comedic beats and
the really heavy drama stuff as well.
Marvel really likes there main protagonist
to be relatable characters.
They kind of have to be able to wisecrack
but also do the heavy stuff as well.
It's getting to the iron fist of it all.
Because marvel did attempt a martial arts
project before but is wound up being a total
disaster.
No matter how bad ass the Shang Chi sequels
wind up being some of you might still have
iron fist PTSD.
But the movie does go a long way to washing
that bad taste out of your mouth Kevin Feige
kind of saying to the fans no to know don't
worry, we can actually pull this off.
We can do a really really awesome martial
arts movie.
I feel like it's not a spoiler to say there
is no iron fist stuff going on during the
Shang Chi movie.
But I feel like in the future.
A lot of people speculated that that would
be the place to reintroduce that mythology
are that character if they want to do a new
version of him.
Please recast I'll say right now just please
recast a brand-new actor like us of the Shang
Chi movie gets into a whole new mythology.
So it doesn't have anything to do with come
loan or the capital cities of heaven anything
from the iron fist comics.
I will do my full post credit scenes video
on Friday and I'll talk a little bit more
about what they set up in that the post credit
scenes does tease something larger going on
with the 10 rings of power.
So in the comics, the 10 rings of power are
made by the makluans the kind of like space
dragons in the marvel universe.
They don't really do any the makluans during
the movie and they never fully explain all
the details about the 10 rings themselves
during the Mandarin found them thousands of
years ago.
Inserted using then they gave him immortality.
The only tease where they come from this other
realm that this group of people comes from.
It seems like it might wind up being their
version the makluans inside the MCU.
But that is one of the big questions that
they do not answer the just leaving for the
sequels.
So we'll talk more about what that means when
I do my post credit scene video tomorrow.
But when they do get to doing the sequel I
am excited to see how that influences and
changes the MCU.
But it broadens things in a cosmic way that
I was not expecting when you think of kung
fu action movies in the MCU.
You tend to think more ground level action.
Just because his love hand-to-hand combat.
But the movie does get much bigger, much more
cosmic than you're expecting and speaking
of the fight scenes, the action I boarded
than a couple videos talking about some of
their big fight scenes and obviously we have
that Mortal Kombat style tournament happening
with long the abomination in Shang Chi later
in the trailer.
The fight choreographer they had in the film
was from the matrix movies.
He was also one of Jackie chance top men he
wound up passing away after the movie was
finished was very unfortunate but he was a
bad ass fight choreographer so all the traditional
types of fights like hand-to-hand combat martial
arts fights are badass early on one of the
few minor complaints though is that when they
get to the third act and thing sort of escalate
to the more cosmic realm they start using
more their superpowers to fight, the choreography
gets a little bit messier and just not quite
as exciting is some of the traditional hand-to-hand
fights, most of you in on my trailer video
seem like you're already big fans of Tony
Leung from his martial arts movies or other
movies that he's done with long car why most
of the movies he's made have been pretty fantastic.
He actually said that this movie is the first
time.
The actually worked with an American crew
on a film.
So you haven't seen any of his films before
this, I recommend you check them out.
He's done both badass martial arts films,
but also a lot of really awesome drama films
as well.
Anything of his from Won Kar Wai is fantastic,
so be sure to watch some of those the interesting
thing about their dynamic Shang Chi in the
Mandarin during the film is it is way more
of a family vibe that they got into in previous
villain relationships in marvel movies like
before the Shang Chi movie.
I feel like the biggest relationship you see
between a villain in their relative family
members was during avengers infinity war and
Avengers endgame with thanos and Gamora like
him throwing her off the cliff that was actually
really powerful moment.
But at the time there was a brand-new thing
for marvel like oh this giant cosmic villain
next he has a family that he cares about in
a relatable kind of way.
Usually that's one of people's biggest complaints
against marvel movies is that the movies are
only as strong as the villains in some of
the movies have pretty terribly written villains,
the difference with Tony lands Mandarin character
is the entry has a genuine arc during the
film start to finish.
Like you learn how he became the Mandarin
in ancient China thousands of years ago how
the legends about him were spun how he became
this great warlord using the 10 rings of power,
then how he fell in love started the family
had Shang Chi, his sister, how he stops being
the Mandarin for a while and then why he became
the Mandarin again one of the other post credit
scene teasers gives you an idea for what's
going to happen with the future of the 10
rings organization in the future the MCU.
Like I said I will talk about that tomorrow
when I do my full post credit scene video
all the supporting cast to a really solid
job to Michelle Yeoh's amazing and pretty
much everything that she does so no big surprise
there that he they put around see milieu was
great.
Although there's not a whole lot of his sister
in the movie the kind of hyper up in the trailer
is a pretty big character and she is a pretty
big character.
They sort of tease that at the end of the
film, but a lot of what you see from her in
the trailer is about what you get from her
in the film she doesn't have a lot of speaking
lines she's kind of shows up is really bad
ass for a little while has some good scenes
with him and then is important for the end
of the film and it is kind of tease a larger
role for her during one of the post credit
scenes.
I'm assuming that when they get to the sequel
shall be a much bigger character.
Even though it seems like Awkwafina is mostly
in the film.
Just for comedic relief their pairing together
her in Shang Chi together as a comedic pair
actually works pretty well during the film
that she work as a couple.
Even though they themselves are not a couple
of the kind of tease that there might be some
kind of romantic relationship with them in
the future.
They played a little bit like the iron man
Pepper Potts relationship only.
She isn't pining over him.
The way the Pepper Potts was clearly in love
with Tony for a long time before he ever noticed
her.
Like imagine a funnier version of Pepper Potts
who isn't totally in love with Iron Man at
the beginning is much more important part
of the plot throughout the film, then Pepper
Potts was in the first Iron Man film.
I was also very happy that they finally explain
what happened to Trevor after that one-shot
all hail the king the iron man three one shot
during that they tease that the real Mandarin
is after him for revenge using his name Kree
all this negative attention around the 10
rings so that getting a huge spoilers yes
they do answer what happened to Trevor in
a satisfying way.
Overall I do feel like it's going to go down
as one of the better marvel movies like the
good half of marvel movies.
Because are so many of them.
Now maybe enough to break into my top 10 not
quite top five like it's not Captain America
Winter Soldier good but is still a pretty
solid movie.
My top 5 and my top 10 marvel movies tend
to shuffle after every new marvel film little
bit but I do give it a lot of extra points
for pushing into this fresh new territory
the same way that the Black Panther movie
did like here's something brand-new that you've
never seen before.
But that feels like a marvel movie, so if
you have seen the movie or what you do have
a chance to see it do write your reactions
in the comments below.
Like us in my Shang Chi post credit scene
videos will post tomorrow will do full Easter
egg breakdowns this weekend.
There is a lot of really exciting stuff that
they do set up for the future the MCU in Avengers
five during the movie.
Speaking of people ignoring wants advice you
can click here for my full Spider-Man No Way
Home trailer video and Doctor Strange going
off the rails in my full what if episode 4
dark Doctor Strange episode video.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see in the next video!